So now there's this idea that there's a,
there's the possibility of opening up
a line of communication between human
psyche and the transcendent divine.
And there's a,
there's a great image of Christ as Pantry.
They're so creative,
the world at just one
of the first mosaics,
if I remember correctly.
And I wish I knew,
remember where it was,
but I don't,
but it's,
it's a very interesting image.
I'm having a carving of it made
at the moment by a friend of mine.
But you see Christ's face in me portrayed
in a medieval manner and he's holding
a book.
So it symbolizes the importance of,
of the book,
you know,
uh,
as a means of transmitting wisdom.
And his face is very asymmetrical
and the eyes are different.
One side and the other,
and one half of the face
represents the human part.
And the other side of the face
represents the divine part.
And you know,
I also think about that psychologically
because I do think that that's the right
way to conceptualize human beings is that
there's an aspect of us that's mortal
and cumin and limited,
but there's an aspect of us that's
transcendent and divine as well.
And it's latent in some sense.
But there are times when
it manifests itself.
And this is not speculation,
right?
This is like the oldest
experience of human beings.
Now,
it's not necessarily an
easy experience to have,
but it's reported everywhere.
And it can be reliably induced as we've
discussed before by chemical means,
which,
and I don't know what that means exactly.
We've talked a little bit about
silicide mushrooms for example.
And you could say that the mystical
experiences that have been invoked in the
newest experiments down it at Johns
Hopkins are derangements or forms of
psychosis,
you know,
because they have some similarity
to psycho psychotic experiences.
Although psychotic people were given
LSD in the 60s and they always said that
that was something different
than what they were having.
And if you give psychotic
people amphetamines,
you can make them worse.
So there biochemically separate.
And we know that.
And,
but also the thing that's so interesting
about the psilocybin experiences is
that they reliably produce mystical
experiences that the people rate as among
the most important
experiences of their life.
And among those who have
the psychedelic experience,
positive things happen to them.
And so that kind of messes with
the whole psychosis theory,
right?
Because what are you going to do?
You're going to claim that you give
someone a pill and they have a psychotic
break and then they're healthier.
It's like,
no,
that isn't how psychotic breaks work.
You're not healthier after having one.
You're like,
you're a broken egg and it's not
easy to put you back together.
So,
and we know that people all over the
world have discovered every manner of
psychedelic substance
that you could possibly,
while you imagine there's lots of hungry
people wandering the earth for a long
time and they eat every damn thing
they could get their hands on and now,
and then something very peculiar
happened as a consequence.
So,
so here I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the Shamani tradition because
it's associated with Jacob's ladder.
So,
um,
according to Elliot at Mircea Eliade,
who was a great historian of religion,
a compatriot of viewings and,
and,
and the influenced each
other quite substantially.
Eliana believed that shamanism that used
psychedelics was a degeneration from
the original,
more pure shamanism.
But I think later scholarship has
demonstrated that that's incorrect,
that the show ritual per se was a direct
consequence of the use discovery of Ed
and ritualistic use of
psychedelic substances.
But anyways,
Eliana identified three pathways
to shamanism and the Sharman in it,
in a tribe was more educated than the
typical person with a larger vocabulary
and was the repository
of the oral tradition.
And so learned all the stories
that had been passed down.
Word of mouth.
And people by the way,
are very,
very,
can very,
very accurately tell the same
story across generations.
That's been quite well documented.
So,
and,
and people who can't read
really can remember cause
what else are they gonna do?
Their memories are far greater than
modern people's memories because we can
forget everything because
we can just look it up.
But they remembered things
because they had no choice.
My father knew someone
who was a illiterate and,
and,
and couldn't use numbers either when,
when he grew up in Saskatchewan,
you know,
60 years ago.
And he was,
uh,
he had a sheep,
if I remember correctly.
And although he couldn't count,
he knew if one of his sheep was
missing because he knew all the sheep.
And so he could tell just by looking
if one of the sheep was missing but he
couldn't count.
And so,
well,
so people who don't have our
particular set of skills,
first of all,
they're not stupid.
And second,
they have other skills that
we don't understand to,
to fill in the gaps.
So Eliana identified spontaneous vocation.
So you were just,
you had this spirit of a Sharman,
let's say.
So you're probably
extremely high in openness,
let's say from a modern perspective,
hereditary transmission.
So you know,
your father was a showman and your
grandfather was a showman and so forth,
and you got initiated into that
process or a personal quest
in Siberia.
This is from Eliana and Siberia.
The youth who is called to be a showman
attracts attention by his strange
behavior.
For example,
he seeks solitude,
becomes absent minded,
loves to roam in the woods or unfrequently
frequented places has visions and
sings in his sleep.
You know,
if you put someone in a in
a place that's deprived,
that's where you're,
you're deprived.
From a sensory perspective,
it fit normal.
People will hallucinate quite quickly,
so it seems what happens is that if
you dampen down the sensory input,
then you start to become aware of the
background processes of your mind.
It's something like that.
It's like the signal to noise ratio.
I got to get this right.
As the noise decreases,
some of the noise becomes signal,
the background noise becomes signal and
you start to become aware of your own
internal psychological processes.
It's something like that.
He has visions and sings in his sleep.
In some instances,
this period of incubation is marked by
quite serious symptoms among the Yakut.
The young man sometimes has fits of
fury and easily loses consciousness,
hides in the forest,
feeds on the bark of trees,
throws himself into water and fire
and cuts themselves with knives.
We went to a potlatch in northern
northern Vancouver island.
About a year ago and
they had this one dance,
it was the Kwakwaka'wakw natives and
they had this interesting dance that was
the dance of the wild man.
And so the person who invited us was the
wild man and he was dressed up in tree
branches and so forth.
And so he was the person who'd been in
the Bush too long and he came in as a
cannibal and there there was genuine
cannibalistic rites among these people not
so long ago.
And he came in as accountable and
everybody had to wear this like cedar head
dress because if you had
a cedar headdress on,
then the cannibal wouldn't
take a bite out of you.
And they actually took
this route as seriously,
so you should have your
Cedar headdress on.
And so he's looking around the crowd and
there's like 400 people in this place
and he could really act too.
So he's doing this wild man dance.
And then all the women stood up and
started to tight kind of dancing place and
sing and they were taming him.
So that was really cool.
You know,
it was really interesting to see
that because those people are about,
they've had an unbroken
culture for about 13,000 years.
That's how long they've been
out out on the island there.
And it was very interesting to see that
dramatization of the domestication of,
of man by women laid out
in that dance in that way.
But it was also interesting
in relationship to the
shamanic tradition because he
came in as a wild man,
right.
And he had to be re civilized in some
sense and brought back down to earth.
So by whatever method he
may have been designated,
a showman is recognized as such,
only after having received
two methods of instruction.
The first is ecstatic dreams,
trances visions.
The other thing that this guy told me,
and I have no reason to doubt him,
um,
he's also not illiterate person.
Um,
and so has a great memory.
He does carving traditional
carving and he's very good at it.
He carved a 53 foot totem pole that's
now in front of the Museum of art in,
in downtown Montreal.
So if you ever go there,
you can go see it.
I won't be there forever,
but it's there right now.
And uh,
he was taught to carve by his grandparents
and he said that he dreamed in,
you know,
what the Haida images look like.
So the Kwakwaka'Wakw cert,
kind of like the hightest same sort of
imagery he told me that he dreamed in
those images.
So when he dreams,
that's the form that the
things he dreams about takes.
And he also said that he would talk
to his grandparents and his dream.
So if he was working on a piece of wood
and trying to figure out how to carve
it,
and he ran into a particularly
difficult problem,
he dream in his great,
he'd have a conversation
with his grandparents and
they'd help him figure out
how to solve the problem.
And then he'd wake up and
he could go carve the,
and the thing is,
he told me these things
sort of matter of factly,
right?
Like you don't,
you know what I mean?
It wasn't like,
okay,
he was telling me these weird
things that happened to him,
although he was doing that to some degree.
I asked him
a lot of questions about what
he carved and what it all meant.
And um,
you know,
that was just part of his
explanation of how he did it.
And he,
he carved me a couple of doors that I
have in my house and one of them is quite
interesting,
well the,
to make a panel and there
are an underwater scene and
under the water there's a
bunch of,
you know,
mythical monsters.
Some of them are killer whales and I
think there's an octopus down there and
carved in this particular style.
And he said that the other thing that
happens to him when he dreams as he goes
down to the bottom of the water where
these mythical creatures are and he gets
inspiration from them.
And so I thought that was
extremely interesting to,
you know,
we,
we don't know what a mine
that isn't hyper civilized,
let's say hyper literate,
like,
like our minds are,
cause we're so bombarded
by external stimuli can,
we have no idea what the
natural mind is like really.
And so it was quite interesting to,
to,
to listen to that.
And,
and also to see the consequences
cause you've quite a great,
he's quite a great carver.
So the first is ecstatic dreams,
trances visions.
The second is traditional
shamonic techniques,
names and functions of the spirits
methodology and genealogy of the clan.
A secret language.
This two fold teaching imparted by the
spirits and the old master Sherman's
constitutes initiation.
Well,
so you know,
modern people have a problem with that
because we don't really get initiated.
But I would say
it all,
let's say that we're each on a quest
of some sort or you wouldn't be here,
I don't think if,
if you weren't because why
else would you be here?
Can you eat?
And so you're on a quest
of some sort to figure out,
to struggle with the meaning of life,
let's say.
And you don't want to do
that alone because you only
last like 70 years and good
luck figuring it out on your,
on your own.
It's just not going to happen.
It's too complicated and
you'll be too isolated,
right?
If,
if it's just you,
that's insanity.
That's no one can stand that.
And so you hope that other people have
things to tell you when that your culture
has something to tell you.
You know,
so you're on a quest,
maybe not with the same intensity as
a shit shamonic initiat but you know,
let's give you some credit.
And then you're also trying to understand
the wisdom of the past and that that's
the second part of this.
It's like,
okay,
well you're a human being and human beings
have been telling stories for a long
period of time trying to
figure out what's going on,
trying to figure out how to
orient themselves in the world.
And so partly what you're doing here is
exactly what the shamonic initiates does
in the second part of the process,
which is to expose yourself to the degree
that you can to names and functions of
the spirits,
mythology and genealogy of the
clan and the secret language.
There's two fold teaching imparted by
the spirits and the old master Schamens
constitutes initiation.
So it's,
that's the rebirth,
right?
That's,
that's what initiation is.
It's being born again and,
and that's a birth of the
spirit rather than of the body.
It's something like that.
And so it's the rebirth
of an integrated psyche.
That's one way of thinking
about it and a psyche that's,
that's individual,
but also grounded in common humanity
and the wisdom of common humanity.
And that makes you strong,
or at least it makes you stronger.